hey everybody welcome to binge battle my
name is Mark Ellis I am the host of this
show where you the viewer get to
determine who is the winner of each
round and thus the ultimate prize
champion of binge battle today is all
about Breaking Bad to show that
everybody fell in love with this little
show on AMC that nobody really knew what
the hell was going on is that the dad
from Malcolm in the Middle
what what is this show and then all of a
sudden it took off like wildfire by the
end of the show everybody in the world
it seemed was hooked on every twist and
turn that this show took so the way that
you determined your vote here is you're
gonna be clicking that like or that love
button a lot you're also gonna be
commenting in Facebook live so without
further ado let me introduce our
esteemed panelists that you will be
commenting about and voting for on my
right left directions are very hard
right now is Roxy stryer you know her
from screen junkies from Collider you
also know her from her own YouTube
channel and her daily show live at the
Roxy how you doing Rox my own hype woman
right now thanks mark I'm excited
Breaking Bad when the best shows of all
time and being able to argue it the fact
that it's still relevant today years and
years later is so crazy but it is one of
the greatest so I'm excited to be a
winner today and to talk some Breaking
Bad already declaring herself a winner
and I don't know how you feel about this
but I feel like Roxy's setup is very
intimidating I feel like I just got
called into an office and I may not walk
out of it with my gig how do you feel
yeah it sort of seems like she should be
like ranting about the news almost from
this set up like like she's got a John
Oliver takedown about our Co vid 19
response or something like it's it's
much more professional setup than like
me hanging in my living room well your
living room does have an added bonus in
that there might be an appearance from
Milan's a lovable dog taco yeah and then
I get the rock stars taco hey taco
blonde when did you first come about
Breaking Bad did you start right at the
beginning or did you have to catch up
and binge it until you were no I was not
on board for Breaking Bad at first the
kind of felt you know what it sort of
felt like at first when I saw like the
trailers are if I like one of those like
USA Network dad shows like Oh dads are
gonna love this it's like the most
badass guy in the world is a 15 year old
high school teacher like it's such a
weird like Charles Bronson suburban dad
fantasy but I kind of avoided it until
season two and that's what other reviews
were like hey this show is pretty great
and like the acting is really good and
it's going in some interesting
directions so that's when I went back
and like caught up and then I got
totally sucked in immediately
Roxy I think that I came about like
season three or four I think it was
pretty late into the game and then I
binge during a summer or fall and caught
up in time for season four in season
five when did you catch onto Breaking
Bad I'm very embarrassed to admit this
but I watched Breaking Bad at the very
start and then I stopped I I watched it
when it was on live and I stopped a few
episodes in and was like I don't know I
don't know uh and then the review
started coming out and it wasn't until
season three that I was like wait people
are raving about the show maybe I should
go back and give it another shot and I
did and I don't know whether I was in a
bad state of mind or what uh I will say
the first season is a little slower and
so maybe it was just taking a little bit
more but then I benched through so
quickly so starting season 3 was when I
was with the people and right now is
probably the best time to re-watch and
revisit your favorite characters from
Breaking Bad I want to remind everybody
that rottentomatoes.com right now has
pretty much an essential guide called
binge central which is your hubs for all
things that you can binge whether it's a
movie or a TV show that you want to
stream it's got all the different
networks that you can check all of your
favorite content out on they have so
many great lists it's like I saw the
best sports movies I was going through
best comedies this morning they have
like the hundred and fifty best movies
on Amazon what's on Hulu of course all
the Netflix shows you should be checking
out right now so go to Rotten Tomatoes
calm and check out thinj Central as soon
as we're done here but I want you to
stay around because we need your
to participation throughout the duration
of binge battle because like I said
before the audience is going to be
determining who wins each round and thus
who wins the binge battle here today
vote with your fingers click like if you
think Roxy made a better argument during
a particular round or you want to vote
for her overall click love because we
all love LAN Harris if you think lon did
the better job in a particular route or
overall you take your leg back give it a
love take the love back give it a
legging I don't care how you do it you
live your life comment so while we're
having our debate you have the raging
debate in the comment section as well
this first question is gonna be a great
one to start off on because it's very
simple
is it team wall or is it team Jesse so
Roxy stryer I'm gonna give you the
kickoff for a minute is a team wall or
as a team Jesse and why to me this is
maybe the most obvious question of all
of Breaking Bad I don't know how you
watch this show and take away anything
other than being team jesse jesse has
the most incredible character arc but he
also has a really tough past you know he
has been thrown out of his home he comes
from less education and he's in a
completely different
of social class than Walt is and I
understand that Walt made decisions for
his family at first which we find out is
not really why he made all of his
decisions later on but Jesse felt like
that was his only option in life and he
had some really bad mentorship and by
the end of things he's the one who
really wanted to get out he wanted to
change his life we know he's capable of
love we see it many times throughout the
series and when they have to make the
hard decisions jesse is the one who's
always advocating for saving as many
people as possible he tries to save
especially the children he doesn't want
them as part of this war with drugs on
drugs and I think that he's the better
human being but also the one that you
can really get behind you might like
Walt's character better but whose team
do you really want to be on Jesse
pinkman's okay very good opening salvo
there by Roxy
dryers so lawn Harris you're in a tough
position because I received a lot of the
chat room agreeing with Roxy so now your
son teen Walt yeah I mean I think the
question really comes down to less like
who's the better guy they're not real
guys not like who do I want to like be
my dad and when you come down to them as
characters and and how they function in
the show Walt's the active character
he's the one he's got a goal he's got
ambition he's always got a plan
he's the one that's getting them out of
all of these strips Jesse's
fundamentally reactive but sure when you
get down to it when when the psychopath
is holding the gun at somebody else's
head then yeah Jesse's conscience kicks
it don't do it man no oh come on don't
kill him but he's never taking active
steps to prevent those things from
happening he's just living in the moment
realizing he's gotten in too deep at the
last moment and then trying to veer off
course like that's not really the kind
of guy you can get behind as a viewer
where as well as all of this direction
there's like he's making we recognize
that he's making immoral bad choices
that make him a bad sort of fellow but
also as a viewer it would be lying to
say that you're not being pulled through
by Walt's journey and you're not on some
level pulling for him to like get out of
these increasingly dire scrapes so it's
interesting because a lot I'm gonna
stick with you and then I'm gonna give
the last word to Roxie here because it's
team Walter team Jesse so I understand
your point that it you don't want
necessarily the person to be your dad
it's who's the more interesting
character but did you actually find
yourself rooting for Walt over Jesse it
shifts over the course of the show like
by the very end it's sort of undeniable
that I think the the writing staff that
the producers are like look we're not
saying you should be Walter White he's a
bad fellow but up until then I mean
until the last few episodes Walt's your
way into this story he's the guy who's
pulling you through and he's the guy
that fundamentally the audience relates
to not the teen junkie that he pulls
along on his schemes he's the hero he's
the protagonist or the antihero as it
were we're seeing the world through his
perspective and following him on this
journey that's the guy who's team around
Jesse's
I'll be Jessie's present to sort of be
the voice of the world's conscience that
Walt largely ignores alright this is
really getting heated in the comment
section too because I'm seeing
Eileen Rivera making a great point
against team Walt saying that won't kill
it all of Gypsys girlfriend's men also
agreeing with rocks they're saying that
she is teen Jesse so Roxie I'm gonna
give the last word to you in this first
round were you just rooting for Jesse or
did you actually think he was the more
interesting character I think the answer
to that is both mark I'm rooting for
Jesse because he is somebody who's
troubled he's a drug addict and he's
trying every day he's waking up and
trying to be better he goes to rehab
he's fighting his demons and we all have
demons when it comes to Walt Walt could
have solved all of this by dropping his
pride and taking money from his ex
roommate xrx called roommate
ex-girlfriend so if he had just done
that he would have been perfectly fine
but yeah he does watch everybody die and
he does have a hand in killing all of
Jesse's girlfriends and not only that
but just to make sure that he solidifies
himself as the true villain of this show
he watched Jane die and then years later
on the show decided to tell Jesse that
he did that why not just let it be why
do you have to say not only am i okay
with what I did but I need you to know
that's what I did because I liked it
it's predictive he feels at that point
that Jesse was gonna turn him over to
the cops but on the point of Walt
killing Jesse's girlfriend
what really doesn't have that much to do
with the death of Andrea that is the
white supremacist you have kidnapped
Jesse and they're trying to get him to
say and how did the white supremacists
come involved into the picture oh well I
mean but jesse was there to like that's
what that's kind of my point like
Jesse's not innocent of any of this
stuff he's right there he just at the
last minute decides oh wait this isn't
what I wanted and I know I don't see
that as a guy I sort of sympathize with
also as far as Jane goes Jesse's easily
as much at fault he's the one that got
her back into doing heroin he's laying
right there it's just that he's on
heroin and he can't save her so whoa not
totally clean of that one but it's a
it's a shared wall literally tries to
boys and children and doesn't care if
they live or die legitimately something
that happens he tries to he doesn't care
if kids little kids die he is willing to
poison them to go with his war commit
does point out that Walt saved Jesse's
life so if your team wondered team the
other there is one that save the other
ones life but I think you could make the
argument that they saved each other's
lives multiple times but they also got
each other into tougher predicaments
with themselves and their families
multiple times so there's all sorts of
great chatter right now in the comment
section I can barely keep up with it but
Anthony Alicia makes a great point he
says team Hank question mark that would
have been a good argument maybe next
binge battle when we revisit this
Breaking Bad one
Lucy is saying that Roxy's got some
great points Kim says Jesse took
advantage of the situation so thank you
all for your chatter and this is only
the first round you're voting with your
legs with your loves and with your
comments as well and I can finally
render a verdict
yeah huh as we all know from our massive
golf fandom background now that you have
the first point you have the honor of
going first in the next round and that
matter is gonna be all about bring it on
everybody the best supporting character
who was the supporting character MVP
maybe Anthony in the comment section
gets his wish of team Hank one minute
goes to you best supporting character in
one Anthony gets his ways I'm going team
Hank on this one
ah thanks Raider is maybe the most
complicated character from the entire
world of Breaking Bad he's got a lot of
layers when he's first introduced he's
you know the usual kind of like
aggressive in-your-face thuggy kind of
cop he gets off on Authority he loves
being a DEA agent he's riding all of his
colleagues
he's like toss toxic masculinity as a
character but over the course of the
show we keep opening him up seeing more
vulnerability see figuring out more of
what makes him tick learning more about
his marriage with Murray and his
relationship with the the whites and
with his colleagues and it really is
especially watching him go through you
know panic disorder and all of his sort
of mental health issues I really feel
like Breaking Bad was kind of pressing
in this it's a lot of conversations
we're having right now that Breaking Bad
was already talking about a decade ago
with the character of Hank going through
all this you know both in his physical
and his mental rehabilitation I really
love the character and I think it's so
powerful in Ozymandias towards the end
when he finally dies it's maybe the most
impactful death from all of Breaking Bad
and I feel like that's because we've
invested so much and we've come to
become so close to that character I love
that Hank it's one of my favorite gags
in the show rocks is that Hank like most
men did his best thinking on the toilet
that's when he's learning really things
together however as soon as I announced
the premise for round number two and
what that subject was the chat room lit
up saying Saul so well I was taking Hank
Roxy who are you
for yeah I'm really excited about this
one Total Annihilation right now because
I want you guys to legitimately think
about the question the phrasing of the
question supporting character m-v-p who
is the most valuable player now LAN and
I just previously fought team Walter
team Jesse but the point being you are
team Walt and Jesse you are rooting for
Walt and Jesse so who is the most
valuable supporting character in their
journey is it Hank the person who's
coming after them the entire time no
he's actually the least valuable person
in their journey he is trying to get
them arrested or killed he has no value
to what we are trying to do which is get
money for Walt's family and cook
freaking meth so who is the most
valuable player yes of course I am
talking about the man himself Saul
Goodman now why I saw the valuable
player because he is able to get them
out of trouble when nobody else's in
fact when they think about killing him
his argument for why he should live why
he should be able to help them is so
much stronger that they keep him and of
course he is the most valuable player
because as a TV watcher what do you want
you want more Breaking Bad what's better
than having your own spin-off show he's
the one they picked to have a spin-off
show because he is the most valuable
player he gets us out of trouble time
and time again and he saves many lives
along the way Hank is actually the LVP
the least valuable player Wow
Ilan Roxie not only championing someone
that you did not take she went with Saul
Goodman she is throwing a lot of shade
at your boy Hank what would he have to
say for yourself it's a bizarre semantic
argument to be who's the most valuable
supporting character to another
character and I don't even think that
holds together anyway if you think about
since they fell in with Saul Goodman in
season 2 things get much much worse
every season I mean he's not guiding
them on on the true path he's guiding
them to you know becoming targets of Gus
fring to becoming targets of the cartel
to become a you know like it's just more
and more and then to becoming a target
of him
he's trying to kill them for almost the
entirety of season four so it's uh I
think it's an odd
it's an odd way to look at it but even
if you sort of put that to the side I
mean I think Saul Goodman as a character
is comic relief really and Breaking Bad
I mean that's why he's sort of there in
that show
he's like the over-the-top sleazebag
lawyer it what he didn't really come
alive as a character in his own right
until better call Saul which really
leads into the backstory hey that
doesn't really have much of an inner
life in Breaking Bad he's a plot device
and like he throws out a couple zingers
and then he gets out of the way ooh I
did hey Hank kind of did move the action
along because he's forcing our
characters into different corners and
we'll see how they get out of them do
you agree with wand that Saul was just
comic relief and then absolutely not
it's the most offensive thing that
anybody's ever said to Saul in their
life and he's been said some offensive
things have been said to him before you
know we don't want a criminal lawyer we
want a criminal lawyer and that is what
we got with Saul he he launders their
money he's an all-around fixer he yes
things did get worse but not because of
him when you're cooking meth sometimes
things get worse as the years go on
that's just the way it is he saved their
lives and hank was very annoying let's
not forget he was this macho man who
used to make fun of Walt and was kind of
a D nobody really liked Hanks character
at first and yes he did grow as the show
went on but ultimately he was a macho
alpha look at me I'm this dude and he
was kind of a jerk and annoying to watch
for many years Saul was the comic relief
absolutely but he was so much more than
that and that's why they felt the
confidence in giving him a spin-off show
okay this is this is such a fun argument
to watch play out in the comments
section because I'm seeing a lot of
people vote for either one or for Roxy
and I want everybody who hasn't yet to
chime in click like if you're going with
Roxy click love if you're going with
line but I'm also seeing a lot of
characters that the things which you had
talked about so I'm seeing
for Mike in the comment and yeah Gus
fring in the comic oh how bad your not
come up badger was one and then Anthony
said the best that the supporting
character MVP was of course met so I
want to read a couple movies they're
making some great points a Jimmy says if
you didn't have Hank you wouldn't have
Breaking Bad solace comedic relief at
best but then a Marta comes back and
says Hank finds out Walt is Heisenberg
so that's like a Sherlock moment people
are loving Hank but then you also have
Saul and Saul is getting a lot of
support siddharth actually said that
Roxy's argument made me change my answer
to stall and Lucy is as well saying that
Roxy won that one so it's a very close
race here as we get in our final poll
results and we're getting all the
comments I am now able to declare I feel
like I'm doing like a political show
like y'all are running for office and I
had to declare who wanted speech 10% of
Powys reporting enough precincts are
reporting in with their final numbers
that Roxie stryer won the best
supporting character MVP debate and so
saul versus hank narrowly went to saw
and we are tied at 1 to 1 did you expect
anything less when you have two great
panelists and a show that people get as
passionate about as the comment section
proves like Breaking Bad so now for you
I did it for you to your question and
that is in Breaking Bad what is the most
shocking moment
okay so Roxie story you have the honor
after gaining that point around to what
is the most shocking moment in the
lineage of Breaking Bad such a great
question because of all there are so
many shocking moments on this show the
show is a shocking show in general but
the moment that I'm picking is the
moment that we find out that Gus's face
gets ripped off it gets blown off and he
is dead we have been working so hard to
kill us in so many different ways we
didn't know if he was gonna die when he
was gonna die how he was gonna die and
there were so many other setups like
them trying to do the bomb in the
hospital and every time they tried to
kill Gus he just outsmarted them so we
started to think as fans it was never
going to happen but literally throughout
this entire scene in which we know
there's some funny business going on we
don't know the exact plan but we know
that our Hector is working with Walt and
that they they've discussed something
you still don't think he dies because he
walks out of the room and the way this
is shot in profile you believe somehow
someway that Gus was able to make it out
of this explosion and live and it's not
until the final seconds the final
seconds of his life that we know because
we pan over and you see that half of his
face is completely gone he's
straightening his tie he's there
everything's all good and then we see
that any tips on over it was the most
shocking reveal because we didn't know
how if when and then not until the final
second did we believe it actually
happened
yeah depressing for anybody like me who
tries to look good in a suit and still
doesn't look as good as go spring with
half a face yeah as I do with both of
the sides of my face you already have
people agree with you Roxie Gerardo
vandiola says Gus Springs murder is one
of the top moments in Breaking Bad so
lon
the deck has been stacked against you
it's time to stem the tide with your
argument what do you got well maybe it's
a great moment it's a payoff moment and
I think that's kind of my issue with it
as the answer to this question is that
it's a it's a payoff moment we've been
building up to it especially in that
episode
it's the season 4 finale the entire
episode of Mena miners will be called
kill Gus like that's that's what the
mission is
that's what Walters working towards the
entire episode leads you right up to
that moment so yeah what we see his face
like it's really great Lee they worked
really hard on this special event it
looks great Esposito plays it
beautifully it's a really fun it's a
little cartoonish but I'm willing to
forgive the bad it's a really fun moment
but I don't know if it's the most
shocking because it doesn't feel out of
left field so many of the great
shocking breaking bad moments feel
completely out of left field like one
that I thought out that I didn't pick
dead freight from the final season is
where Todd just shoots the little boy on
the trace of norm out of nowhere because
you don't see that coming
you plan upon them you're like we're
gonna have an episode where we figure
out what to do with this kid you just
suck and then just Todd just wipe like
shoot sir so I picked another moment
that I think is akin to that but even
earlier show it's a more pivotal moment
is when Walt watches Jane choke to death
on her own vomit I mean it's it's
shocking because it's so visceral so
brutal usually a TV show would not show
you the chunks coming out of her mouth
and her vibrating and literally watching
her die we watch her along with Walt
it's pretty horrifying Lee done it's
really impactful scene but it's also
important to where it happens in Walt's
a journey this is the first time where
he's really this is not self-defense
this is not a guy is gonna kill you
unless you kill him that's the kind of
stuff we've seen Walt do up until this
point this is where he breaks from that
and it becomes preventative medicine it
becomes I'm gonna kill this person
before they have a chance to mess with
my empire-building and that's a really
key moment for him at a moment that I
don't think the audience was necessarily
prepared for partway through the second
season of the show so that's why I'm
taking that moment all right so the die
has been cast for both competitors here
in round number three member if you
agree with Roxy's argument more than
click like if you agree with lime click
well then comment and let us know your
favorite moments I got a great one from
John lens who says that him and his wife
actually visited a bunch of the
locations in Breaking Bad and so maybe
that's gonna be like a thing to do for
decades to come is go see the house but
maybe the minivans still there go see
all these different locations where some
of these iconic moments happen for me I
would have to say it's when you see
Danny Trejo's ed on the turtle that's
the pretty shocking moment so ahead on
the tortoise would be shocking enough
but I think Hank would agree with you
that was the most shocking moment for
him as well it was definitely his most
shocking moment in his life
Lonnie give me a little bit more support
as to why your moment is more shocking
versus that just as shocking
vo of seeing gusts brings half face I
mean I think that we all assume that
while it's going to do something it may
not be like call an ambulance like the
right thing but I don't think we I don't
think anybody expects leading into that
scene and how much lead up we've been
doing for Jesse's relationship with this
new woman Jane we spent so much of the
season building up who she is as a
person and their dynamic together in
this romance and then we've already had
won't break into that apartment
previously so I don't think anybody
expects that he's just going to stand
there and watch her die and again but
we're going to watch the whole thing
play out in real time right along with
and watch a major character choking to
death and expire and then to just leave
her there also it's really disgusting in
addition to being a very shocking moment
and it's not something that there's a
lot there's an episode of lead up to
it's not like we got to get rid of Jane
like he seems to not be okay with Jane
he just hung out with her dad like it
doesn't seem like the sort of thing he's
preparing to do yeah Roxy this is one of
those situations where I'm glad I just
gets a referee on I don't actually have
to make the the final gavel because this
is a really tough call you all pick two
great shocking moments so can you give
me a little bit away from Juan's
argument here's the thing we already
watched Walt
choke somebody to death we already
watched him use something to strangle
somebody so watching him watch somebody
choke to death is not that shocking he
what's more shocking is when he actually
decides to do that and I think that yes
you're I can't argue that that moment
wasn't incredibly impactful I watched
that scene and you want to cry because
it's so sad but you know what's coming
from the second he walks in the second
we know that Walt sees you know in your
stomach you know in your gut that he's
not gonna save her and that's what made
it not so shocking because we already
knew we already knew that's who Walt was
and it was really sad and it was
disturbing but it was not surprising
when it comes to Gus it was surprising
because we had no idea outsmarted us so
many times we had no idea if we were
ever going to be able to kill this guy
or how we were gonna do it or if he was
gonna get to us first and literally till
the final second the final second we see
him fixing his tie he's all good he's
Superman he made it out of this how'd he
do it we don't know but you believe he
did because we've seen him he has he's a
cat with nine lives we've seen him do it
a thousand times and so it was much more
surprising of a death and much more
surprising of a moment this is two great
answers and I'm getting a lot of backup
from the chat room here Theresa Monroe
pretty much did my job for me she's
listening a bunch of great moments the
tub falling through the ceiling the kid
shooting combo Hank hitting a creep
brother against the car and the guy
jumping out of bed with legs thumps
these are all great and I'm seeing a
little bit of buyer's remorse in the
chat room too because you all brought up
Todd and so now a lot of people wish
that they had taken Todd as their
supporting character and Phoebe's way to
go back to round 2 Todd was in more of
the show I would have picked Todd it's
just that he only shows up in season
five also here's the worst lot about 10
15 seconds to close up shop here in
argument 3 and then I'll go over to
Robin yeah I mean I think it sure if you
were already in a place where it's like
I hey Walt he's the worst guy in the
world of course he's gonna let this
woman die yeah but I was not there yet
at this point of the show also you're
mentioning him choking crazy a to death
but that's that's me or you
he knows Crazy Eights gonna just kill
him if he lets him go
he's got the broken part of the plate
that's a little bit with the plate is
that he didn't want to kill crazy he has
to and he doesn't have to kill Jane
she's just his friend's girlfriend he he
kind of does have he kind of does have
to kill her because here's the thing
she's already blackmailed him she's
already threatened him and he's actually
not even killing her he's just not
saving her do I think he would have
poisoned her necessarily maybe not for a
couple more seasons but watch her die it
was something easy that he could do and
again we all saw that coming the second
he walked in the room we knew what the
decision he was gonna make there was no
question about it because she had
coming at him and her dad had been
coming at him I would say that the plane
crash was more surprising than her
actual death because that we didn't see
coming all right
this is this has been mind-blowing and
it kind of I don't know about how
everybody out there watching it feels we
have almost 3,000 people watching us
live just on Facebook this really makes
me want to revisit Breaking Bad even
more so than I already did because
there's just so many moments that you
kind of remember and you're like oh yeah
that meant this and then that was from
that and so there's so many different
pieces to tie together here in its
thinking about this round I both were
fantastically surprising and shocking
moments but it does seem like the bulk
of the likes I'm not just saying like
because that's how you vote for Roxy
suppose the love would tell you vote for
a while it seems like most people are
saying that the Gus frame just the
reveal just the visceral look of
somebody with half a face like to face
in the dark night that that alone was
the more shocking moment even though
Walt watching somebody choked to death
is no day at the park so in a very
narrow margin Roxy stryer takes a two to
one lead over lon / taco so lon Harris
and his beloved trusty steed taco now
have to get the last point in order to
force a sudden-death bonus question so
Roxy I know you got to be feeling good
going into the final round right now lon
do you think you have what it takes to
tie the leader opposing energy the best
person will win you know what lon I
don't appreciate your maturity it's
Yemen yeah you know just one-word
answers at this point for your final
round you your question is gonna be
breaking about us so many memorable
episodes but we need one for the
all-time best episode alone because
you're you're trailing I'm gonna give
you the option do you want to argue
first or would you rather hear Roxy's
argument against you I'll go first
hit me all right so we're sort of
flipping the last round because I think
this is the best
don't ever face off the season 4 finale
which features Gus Riggs face being
ripped up but I'll tell you why I think
it's a great episode it's not just about
the face I'm gonna take his face off to
movies it's a it's a great episode
overall and it really represents a lot
of what I think people love about
Breaking Bad I love about Breaking Bad
it's it's relentless I mean it's a race
against the clock
it's Gus versus Walt it's like this this
standoff episode cat-and-mouse episode
with lots of twists and turns an
unexpected turn about and a lot of
strategize are gonna think I think
that's one of the most fun elements of
Breaking Bad is watching all these
criminals navigate around one another
but it's also a very funny episode
Walt's in a crazed maniacal desperate
state the whole time he's breaking into
Saul's office he's carrying a bomb
around with him into a hospital you get
that great back and forth with him and
Jesse if after like did you bring the
par meters like what am I supposed to
leave it someone for someone to fly so I
mean I think it brings together all of
these different elements that are so
great about Breaking Bad into one
package and I mean you know it's very
tempting to pick stuff from like the end
of the show when everything's kind of
paying off but those episodes get very
grim and I what I love about 3 & 4 is
that it's maintained the sort of lighter
aesthetic while also being incredibly
intense alright it's one hair has thrown
everything he has at Roxy Strider trying
to get the tie here we apologize if some
of our folks have an audio glitch there
for a minute but we're back now and
everybody can hear the arguments just
fine so Roxy the table has been set
what's the best episode in the history
Breaking Bad well without a doubt you
just named a top 10 episode for sure I I
gotta say it is a great episode but it
is not the greatest episode the greatest
episode of course is Ozymandias this is
an episode in which some of the biggest
moments happen in the entire season and
it's not just one moment we also have a
variety of different situations going on
where we've got action we've got clever
dialogue of course this is the episode
in which we lose
hanck which was probably the the most
crushing blow of the entire season but
the way he goes out is the most
incredible scene and you know he he
really delivers in that moment and even
if prior to that you have any kind of
feelings about Hank your your gun it
because the way that he we lose him is
so devastating and then when he says you
know you're the smartest guy but you
couldn't see he made up his mind ten
minutes ago oh it wrenches at me every
time oh this is also when Walt becomes
he's very far gone here he lets them say
that okay you can kill Jesse he gives
the go to clear killed Jesse instead
they end up kidnapping him which leads
to some of the most gruesome stuff that
we have seen on this show and that's
saying something
we also have the iconic knife fight the
knife fight with Skyler and Walt and
when she finally puts her foot down this
is the moment I know that Skyler gets a
bad rap on the show but this is the
moment that Skyler stands up and says
I'm not doing this anymore
we are not running with you I am taking
care of my family we also have the the
kidnapping of the baby which we don't
know talk about shocking we don't know
what Walt's gonna do because we don't
trust him anymore
what's he gonna do with this child is he
going to let the kid go back with the
mom and then there's the the incredible
phone call the incredible phone call in
which he does clear Skylar's name and
we're questioning what is this call
about what is happening why is he
calling her the B word all of us this
doesn't sound like him and he's
exonerating her so it there's so many
twists and turns and this is the episode
that makes people cry is the episode he
reveals that he killed Jane this is the
episode that you hate Walter White more
than any other episode of the show and
it's action-packed and perfect perfect
television both are mentioned in the the
top ten at probably the top five or top
three all-time Breaking Bad my favorite
comments so far is from Ivan Buccola who
just says as in the fly but let's now
the boy is no longer in there picnic I
almost picked that I do like that one
too it's very
we clever I love it as a top 10 also I
love that episode and I I think that was
the episode where we're watching okay
this ryan johnson guys should make more
movies so somebody we have our wars we
have Roxy again vote with your heart
with the love if you think lon won this
round vote with the like with the thumbs
up if you think Roxy won and comment
with who you want or who your favorite
stars or episode or supporting MVPs any
of it right now in the comments section
lawn Harris the die goes back to you for
30 seconds and rebuttal for your life I
think we basically just heard it like
that that is like awesome a nice is a
great episode but it's wrenching just
like Roxy said it's it makes you hate
the character that you've come to enjoy
watch it it's a bunch of people doing
the exact place we saw Marie Schrader
playing that in that clip that's great
if you need to end the story there but
that's not what hi Breaking Bad is to me
like that's not what the show is it's
about Breaking Bad it's about Walt going
from being this every man to his
downfall by the time we get to our man
Diaz downfall complete he's Tony Montana
and we're watching him get his
comeuppance in I'm not saying it's not
satisfying and it's not a good tap to
the story I mean it's the payoff for
that setup that we've been watching the
whole time but the setup in the journey
is the lot of the fun and watching Walt
when he's still navigating this world
and finding his way in it it's a lot
more fun and represents more of the
heart of what Breaking Bad is as a show
to me than the very dramatic very somber
let's tie all these pieces together and
show Walt
finally getting his at the sense alright
rocks
thirty Seconds to win over the chat room
lon yours is a gutting episode two
because we know what Walt is capable of
now we know he's capable of killing a
child and that is something that he is
not above I think that the the best part
is the actual film making of Ozymandias
and the juxtaposition of Murray not
knowing what has happened and the
beautiful filmmaking of her saying he
has Walt dead to rights he's got him in
cuffs
it's everything's done and we are
no as an audience that Hank is never
coming home and she does not know that
that being the through line of the
episode is so such genius filmmaking
because usually they wouldn't tell the
story like that we would be suspended
and and we wouldn't know either we would
be in the Murray position but the fact
that they cute us in on it so early on
in the episode doesn't end with Hank
dyeing it starts with that ten minutes
in brilliant decision and unlike
anything we see on TV today I have so
many episode recommendations now to fill
my weekend with veggie has a good one
says the favorite episode for them is
the Don Eladio shootout Gerardo Santa
salute I agree with you to our dough
this is this is a really tough one that
comes down to the wire and Mitchell did
like I don't know if you want to cry
foul play but Mitchell's you can say in
the chatroom that people should be
voting for one simply because they want
to see another round
okay we are gonna go to the judges how
many likes how many loves that's
important I'm for it too too ridiculous
Roxie's dryer is defeating lawn Harris
no more because lawn Harris has won with
his episode face off I would say this is
a mild upset of the Ozymandias episode
it is two to two and now we enter
sudden-death it's gonna work a lot like
a normal round you vote with your like
with your heart and in the comments
section for the winner of the Breaking
Bad challenge here today on binge battle
before we get into the final tiebreaker
sudden-death round I want to give a big
shout-out to Fandango now thank you so
much for supplying everybody with the
promo codes for the trivia contest
winners during our pre-show that's right
we get to do this thing again make sure
you're here on time because we do some
trivia it's not too hard to answer and
you might get a Fandango now promo code
alright with all that out of the way
lawn Harris Roxie Australia all been
great participants so far your
tiebreaker question is would you eat the
food at Lowe's poise hermanos no sorry
that's that's just my personal yes
absolutely
yes the actual question is Walt
redeemable
okay so Alana I'm gonna put you back in
the hot seat because you just tied Roxie
to force it over time so on in a minute
or less why is Walt
redeemable or is he not I don't know I
don't know what we pre picked for the
answers for this so I don't want to mess
up Roxy you're good Ike I just do it
you got this okay okay so rush you
either way Wow love that confidence I'm
gonna say no I don't think well
ultimately is redeemable by the time you
get to be end of Breaking Bad I think
that we're with him for a while I think
that there's a while that you could
excuse his behavior but I think after a
while writers and the the filmmakers
kind of tip their hat that there was
always more to this than the cancer the
family this was pride and it goes right
back if Yuri watched the pilot it's
really striking there's a moment in the
pilot where he's you know he's working
at the carwash and bogged on the guy who
owns the car wash is making him actually
clean people's cars he sees himself as
Takashi or he's above it all but Bogdan
is like a guy called in sick you got to
go out there and watch the cars yourself
and he feels humiliated especially when
one of his crummy students shows up and
kind of bullies and makes fun of him for
being here watching other people's cars
and it's at that moment is really the
whole show in a nutshell Walt feels like
less of a man he feels like he doesn't
provide for his family people don't
respect him he got cheated out of that
company he was gonna start with his
college friends and they made all this
money and he didn't and he's just this
lowly guy who's scraping along and
that's really what this journey is about
and then that sort of capped off in
season five when he tells Skylar he's in
the Empire business like it's just like
he says in the in the finale to err he
was always doing this for himself
it was always purely greed and ego
motivated and he was using the cancer as
an excuse to kind of do this thing he
already wanted to do if you actually
were called to in the pilot they're
watching on TV about the bus that Hank
and Steve Gomez made and he's already
this is before he knows he has cancer
he's already asking like oh you can make
that kind of money huh like it's already
in his mind so I think knowing all that
we've come to know about Walt I think
this was always in him and circumstances
came together allowing him to finally go
through with it and I don't think
that's a redeemable guy okay lon
redeeming his argument very astutely
Roxy stryer which side would you be on
is Walt redeemable you know I think this
this depends who you are as a person and
how you look at people are murderers
redeemable are drug dealers redeemable
and I am somebody who believes that
everybody everybody is and there are
things that you can do always otherwise
why do you believe that there is the
ability to change why do you believe in
humanity if you don't think anybody can
change or grow or redeem themselves then
what are any of us really doing here so
has Walton some horrible things in his
life absolutely and I talked earlier
about for those reasons I was team Jesse
but ultimately at the end of the day
when Walt was able and given the chance
to redeem himself after he had removed
himself from the situation and really
thought about everything that happened
he came back and he saved Jesse's life
and he came back and whether or not he
did it for pride proudful reasons
whether or not the money and the drugs
were about feeling like he had an empire
he came back and made sure that his
children were taken care of and he
didn't have to do that he made sure that
they got the money that they so needed
and that was his goal in the first place
so he makes sure his family is taken
care of and he saves his partner's life
and I think that those two things made
it so that we know he is redeemable and
you know what he gave his life for that
and that is the ultimate thing that you
can do there was nothing more to be done
and I think that uh and in the end of
the day he did redeem himself sterling
and not only argument from roxies dryer
but lon I feel like I can become a
better person I think that I might start
turning my life around after that
inspiration I'm inspired
Ron I'm gonna give you about 20 seconds
then Roxy's gonna have bout 20 seconds
to make your final argument and then the
audience once again is going to decide
who our winner of today's binge battle
is lon
go if you're talking about the general
concept of can people be redeemed well
what's the one thing we think of when
you want to be redeemed if you're a
repented murderer if you're
repentant drug dealer it's that word
repentant you've got to be I recognize
what I have done and I'm going to make
amends to make it up what doesn't really
ever get there he still thinks that he
was fundamentally justified it was fun
he was good at it it was a things you
like to do that's my money
he's he's still very caught up in these
ideas it doesn't feel like a person who
genuinely did the hard work of turning
over a new leaf and has recognized the
flaw in their ways it feels like a guy
got caught and coroner doesn't like his
new lights in a cabin in New Hampshire
is eager for a way out and sure he does
he does the right dress accept things
right for people before he goes but it's
out of guilt as much as a real feeling
of duty or responsibility for justice
and I think that's really what would be
required for a redemption story like
okay Roxy yeah I think the word in binge
battle actions speak louder than words
and maybe he didn't verbalize out loud I
repent what I have done has been
horrible but he shows that in his
actions by coming back he never needed
to come back he was in the clear he
could have lived out the rest of his
life in a cabin and he did not he came
back and he fought for his loved ones
which is how he started this journey and
maybe he went awry throughout the
journey but by the end of it he really
did accomplish the goals he set out to
do and they were pretty selfless goals
so I think that he lost himself along
the way as many of us do in life but by
the end he found himself and he was able
to redeem himself by ultimately
succeeding in giving his loved ones what
they needed okay if I'm a teacher if I'm
like Walter White but instead of
teaching chemistry I'm teaching some
sort of debate class or maybe English it
y'all just gave a plus reports okay you
did your homework you read the source
material you watch the show and you've
both delivered eloquently I'm looking at
the chat and it is very almost 50/50
here Lucy Fitzgerald says she loves
Roxy's argument she's going with Roxy
Ivan says ask yourself this if what were
to live would Jesse ever want to see him
again I even kind of doubts it one of my
favorite premises is from Al
xander James Hamilton which if your name
is Alexander Hamilton no dueling anytime
soon so see him in jail getting free
cancer treatment and helping the DEA or
something but we never got that
opportunity and Edward Harrell has my
favorite comment over time here we go
you are corrected and what a way to go
out tie two two two two you voted with
your thumbs up you voted with your
hearts you voted with your comments and
in the end the winner of the Breaking
Bad binge battle is no there's no drum
roll okay I'll just announce me at Roxy
do you want to rub it in to LOB's face
further
oh no no number one does not look back
at number two to rub it in I will be a
gracious winner and say lon
it was a true honor my friend to beat
the crap out of you thank you for her
playing okay can we just put the lawn in
the winner's circle just so I can feel
good about himself - lets make wanna
champion whoo that sounds like me the
Boston and me is rubbing off on you
good good before we get out of here
just a quick Breaking Bad question and
this is not a debate so I'm just curious
do you all have like a favorite like if
you were a senior in high school and you
had to use a Breaking Bad quote to be
your senior quote what would you use do
you have anything at the ready I know
I'm surprising you all with this I just
wanted to see what you'd say what am i
one of my favorite quotes I don't know
how great it would be as a senior quote
I didn't know that was part of the
premise going in mr. Ellis but one of my
favorite quotes in general is that when
it's the first meeting at Las Vegas
hermanas between Gus and wall and and
wealth is like you know asking - look
why don't you want to work with me my
got the best product everybody loves the
blue meth and and Gus it is very you
know dry aloof matter just says you are
not a careful man and it's such a it's
such a fascinating way to look at it and
that really is a lot of the story is
about well it's just not able to be
carefully he wants to he's passion he
wants to get back at people who would
say
corners he wants to be number one and
he's not willing to do what Gus is which
is to sit back be very patient by his
time move the pieces around the board
and I think it's so great to consider it
in light of Gus's journey to where that
becomes his downfall is not being as
careful once he gets so fed up with
Jesse and Walt and everything that's
happening III think that actually works
for senior coin yeah
Roxy if I if I pick up a yearbook and
I'm signing it I say hey have a great
summer see you at the pool xxoo but then
what senior quote am I gonna see
attributed to your name so I would amend
one of their quotes and so it would say
smoking marijuana eating Cheetos and
masturbating do constitute plans in my
book so they do constitute as plans that
definitely is my senior quote thank you
for asking and I'm pretty sure that's
actually what I wrote so yes I actually
came up with that line they took it from
my senior quote ya know why she's the
champion of binge battle I think you
just got your answer uh-huh so before we
say goodbye here to the kids I want
remind everybody out there watching
right now go to Rotten Tomatoes comm and
check out binge central that's your hub
for all things binging right now I know
it's a tough time I know you can't be
around your friends and your family as
much as you want to you can't give
anybody hugs but hey you can hang out
with us in this virtual community that
we have so go check out binge central
right now and investigate the new shows
you can watch and then zoom or Facebook
live or Instagram live with your friends
afterwards and have these kind of
debates because this is what we hope to
inspire right now it's more fun than
anything else you can do currently and
until we can go outside again and be
safe check out all the cool content on
rottentomatoes.com so a lot of roxies we
say goodbye I want to see what your
binge pics are for the folks that are
going into the weekend looking for
something to watch Roxie what are you
staring them towards you know I am an
absolute TV junkie so I will say I'm
watching far too much right now but the
things that I'm watching that you have
to check out too hot to handle
yo this is the craziest thing I have
ever seen it is on Netflix and the
premise is they put a bunch of 20
something-year-old
horny people on an island together and
tell them that they will win more money
if they don't sleep together and these
people are incapable of not sleeping
together it is phenomenal television
must must watch I don't know if the it's
quite in the Breaking Bad genre of
television but it's a great one but
probably more similar to a Breaking Bad
type thing peaky blinders I'm binging
for the first time I'm behind on this I
know but holy crap I can't believe this
is a hidden gem still this deserves to
be up there with like Breaking Bad The
Sopranos peaky blinders is so so good
it's phenomenal television a couple
others that I'm doing I'm a big bachelor
person now so listen to your heart it's
their new spin-off or you're falling in
love with people who are fellow
musicians which is awesome
just finished Ozark definitely check out
out the third season was phenomenal as
were the first two and sex-education
just binge that and sex education is
hysterical
it's raunchy it's weird and certainly
worth your time Roxy I think it's fair
to say you like TV is a TV ban yeah I
think you could say that I'm a fan those
are all fantastic pixel on Harris what
do you got for and and look I know this
is for everybody watching but I'm kind
of using y'all for my own personal
devices as well because I want something
to watch besides NFL draft coverage yeah
sure I've also seen some of too hot to
end how long do you think we're making
that show like three weeks they're
acting like they're being asked to not
have sex for a decade I know I know
like a few weeks guys will be fun it's
ridiculous it's incredible I do you
think it was four weeks long I think
that's what it was that's like a month
you'll be fine
while we're done I've been watching
recently I also really loved season 3 of
Ozark that kind of took a year to grow
on me but season 2 I thought was really
strong and then season 3 is the best yet
that just keeps getting better and
better I also really enjoy des which was
that FX show that was streaming on Hulu
it's from Alex garland the guy did
anihilation in ex machina really trippy
head-trip crazy metaphysical sci-fi but
but still like good characters like it
still has thriller elements very
watchable and terrific performances
there I really enjoyed that one oh and
uh just one that I love that is just not
watched enough that everybody should
watch is Hannibal I know that it seems
like oh another Hannibal Lecter thing
I've seen the movies whatever it's a
totally brilliant reimagining of the
character Mads Mikkelsen I think is the
best ever Hannibal Lecter and I just
always recommend that show when people
are looking for something new to watch
you all have given me a full plate here
and so as we say goodbye I want to
encourage everybody out there to check
out both Lana and Roxy and all their
exploits on social media on Twitter you
can follow on Harris at launch this ello
and as it's a pretty pretty nice score
there with that handle and then rock
subscribe she got her name at Roxy
strives to make sure that you follow
both of them become a fan as if you
weren't already and we appreciate you
all tuning in to this episode of binge
battle huge thanks once again to
Fandango now for helping us get those
trivia games going and getting the promo
codes to you the fans so use those promo
codes use them wisely maybe use them on
something that rocks you on recommended
for our incredible tech team behind the
curtain that's helping make all this
magic possible the great team of Oh
Fandango and Rotten Tomatoes and of
course
Roland Harris and Roxy stryer my name is
Mark Ellis and by my count if you get
money on too hot to handle that means
that somebody owes me about an 11
million dollars buy business with I'll
do the math and we'll get back to you
and we'll see y'all soon have a great
day and have a great weekend everyone
[Music]